left continues its attempts to purge
literally everyone from everything who
does not agree with their points of view
so there is a show it is called real
housewives of salt lake city right it's
a spin-off on the real housewives at
sierras and it is filled with women who
are famous for doing responsible and
caring and wonderful things for one
another oh wait no it's famous mostly
for women being irresponsible and kind
of to one another that's sort of
the the basis of the show well now
there's one woman who has not made the
cut her name is jenny wenn from the real
housewives of salt lake city and she has
been thrown off the show
why because her social media posts were
deemed racially offensive
her old facebook post disparaged
protesters and the black lives matter
movement
fans of the reality tv show amanda that
should be fired which fans how many fans
seven it's usually seven fans she made
social media comments amid the 2020
protest that occurred following the
killing of george floyd wen apologized
last week never do that never ever ever
apologize it is a waste of time see in a
normal world you'd apologize for stuff
you do wrong but in this world even if
you apologize for stuff you do wrong
that's just an excuse for them to chop
off your head bravo said in a statement
we recognized we failed to take
appropriate action once our offensive
social media posts were brought to our
attention moving forward we'll work to
improve our processes to ensure we make
better informed and thoughtful casting
decisions
she
said that she regretted writing her
remarks that i want to acknowledge and
apologize for my deleted post from 2020
that resurfaced at the time i thought i
was speaking out against violence i've
since learned how offensive and hurtful
my words were i regret these posts i'm
sincerely sorry for the pain they caused
now one of the things that is super
annoying about
the articles like this is they never
tell you exactly what she said okay so
you actually have to dig to find what
she said that was so horrifying and
terrifying and absolutely evil and and
just just the worst thing in in the
world
okay so what did she do
okay well she um she called some people
who were burning things and hurting
people blm thugs and violent gangs
oh no that's terrible that's that's
super racist why
why if you set things on fire and hurt
people i'm pretty sure you should be
called the thug i don't care what your
race is if you if you set fire to things
and hurt people and you're associated
with black lives matter this makes you a
black lives matter thug just as if you
are associated with antifa this makes
you an antifa thug and if you're a
person who's beating up a cop on january
6th through january 6 thug like this is
an all-purpose word as it turns out but
you're apparently not supposed to say it
when it's associated with black lives
matter
what exactly did she do that was so
terrible
she said quote hundreds of blacks shot
many killed including children by other
blacks every week over a thousand
officers violently injured some
permanently by rioters anarchists
rioting in major cities every night
which has caused billions of dollars of
destruction to private and public
property and you still think police
officers are the problem you are an
idiot
this gets you fired now
really like you say that police are the
solution to crime
and that the real problem for the black
community when it comes to violence
against black citizens is other black
people just like the real problem for
the white community when it comes to
violence is generally other white people
and the cops aren't the problem this
gets you fired now
like i i don't understand how this this
is this is super duper terrible
okay and then apparently she showed
another meme and it showed two cartoon
characters one an elderly white woman
and the other middle-aged white man
talking with a man staring at six
figures bumper stickers on the back of
her car that normally represent family
members he said no that's not my family
that's how many rioters i've hit the
cartoon white woman said
okay i mean politically incorrect sure
is that racist it doesn't say the race
of the people they could have been
antifa protesters also
and then there was another one that she
posted that was a picture of ken zhang's
character from community shouting and it
said if you follow the officer's orders
you won't get shot
okay i mean
all right this now gets you canned
because a few idiots right into bravo
now listen i don't care what happens on
the real housewives of salt lake city
i've never seen an episode i will never
watch an episode because i would rather
gouge out my own eyeballs with a spoon
than watch an episode of a show like
that with that said should the lady lose
her job because she said that she likes
the cops and she doesn't like rioters
i'm confused are you supposed to hate
the cops and love her apparently
apparently that is what is necessary
right now so that's good
meanwhile apparently we are going to get
the politically correct version of snow
white and the seven dwarves if peter
dinklage has his way so peter dinklage
is of course
the uh the
actor from game of thrones and and he
was in uh one of the avengers movies
avengers end game i think
and um
and he's very angry at snow white and
the seven dwarfs he calls it a an effing
backwards story
he said there's a lot of hypocrisy going
on literally no offense to anyone but i
was a little taken aback when they were
very proud to cast a latina actress as
snow white but you're still still
telling the story of snow white and the
seven dwarves
okay so i mean
i'm glad that he's allowed to say it it
is sort of bizarre that the the story is
is about a woman literally named snow
white but
it's a latina actress i mean that that
it's strange i mean you can say it's a
little counterintuitive casting but what
he's really mad about is that the studio
depicts dwarves in snow white and the
seven dwarfs he says you're progressive
in one way but then you're still making
that effing backwards story about seven
dwarves living in a cave together what
the f are you doing man have i done
nothing to advance the cause for my
soapbox i guess i'm not loud enough i
don't know which studio that is but they
were so proud he knows exactly which
studio it was he just wants to work for
disney in the future because marvel is
owned by disney
by the way peter dinklage complaining
that that stereotypes about dwarves are
used in entertainment the man would not
have a career if stereotypes about
dwarves were not used in entertainment
i'm sorry to say that but it happens to
be the case i mean game of thrones he
literally plays a dwarf right and then
that dwarf violates a lot of the
stereotypes but that is part of the
story right that is part of what game of
thrones is playing upon
as matt walsh pointed out he is correct
the entire shtick that he had in elf was
a joke about him being a dwarf and then
will ferrell thinking that he was an elf
because of it and him being offended by
it
i mean it happens to be the case that
peter zinklage i mean this this is his
role in literally every movie gets cast
because of his stature i mean this is
this is not
pretend like
isn't he a new production of cyrano de
bergerac i think it's because of this
again again this is not a negative about
dwarves about people who suffer from
dwarfism that's that's not people who
have dwarfism i hesitate to say suffer
from because there are a lot of people
who have dwarfism who are not suffering
from dwarfism in any case people who
have dwarfism
are cast in movies largely because of
their dwarfism and this happens to be
the case with peter's english also are
we supposed to pretend that the dwarves
of myth are the same as just people
suffering from dwarfism now like this is
the same thing
there are many many tales throughout the
the myths of of the norse gods that that
are related to
dwarves right those dwarves also have
other characteristics like they mine a
lot and and churn the earth and all of
this sort of stuff
is all that offensive to dwarves now
like what
okay but we're supposed to
what just kowtow to to peter dinklage
because he has some notes about the
grimm brothers
pretty incredible meanwhile you have
neil young telling spotify that they
should either pull his music or pull joe
rogan
well i guess it's goodbye to neil young
then
because joe rogan has 11 million
listeners per episode so um
catch you later neil
it is incredible how much celebrities
think they get to reshape the culture
around us based on the fact that we
recognize some of their music and some
of their faces
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe